the strength of the force and the power
of magic how could you compare to
abstract concepts that are indefinite
infinite and invisible I know but to
start will treat all footage like it's
real video evidence make physicists
study it to extract hard numbers on
their attributes then have them compete
in a challenge of our own design to
crown one the most powerful this is
power levels today we're comparing two
ideas that make up the fabric of their
fictional universes the force from Star
Wars and magic from Harry Potter we'll
see which one grants a master of their
art the fastest movement the ability to
lift the most weight and which signature
tool can channel the most energy a
lightsaber or a wand winner of each
challenge gets a point most points at
the end of all three is crowned our most
powerful ready let's go to start we're
making obi-wan and Voldemort the fastest
Jedi and wizard we could find footage of
race each other around the maus ESPA
circuit pod racetrack let's start our
comparison by measuring this shot of
obi-wan using his for speed powers from
Looney Tunes I mean The Phantom Menace
we can use Liam Neeson's height as a
ruler then see how many Neeson's they
travel and a given period of time
fun fact an imperial star destroyer is
829 muezzins long Obie's top speed is 26
point 5 meters per second as for Magic's
top speed let's look at Voldemort flying
past Hogwarts we can estimate the size
of parts of the castle then time how
long it takes old voldie to fly by
giving him a top speed of forty three
point four meters per second now that we
know their capabilities we'll use this
map of the Boonta Eve track from the
book star wars complete locations to
measure out the real tracks distance and
see how fast they each finish the course
they're off Voldemort puts in a lap time
of just 12 minutes with obi-wan
stumbling behind at nineteen point five
I guess Anakin's friend was right about
pod racing all along this is wizard
little boy because magic takes this
challenge and wins point number one for
challenge - it's time for Yoda to battle
Grindelwald than I do you even lift off
will determine their max telekinetic
force then see how long it would take
each one to pull a butterbeer into their
hand from 50 meters away the best clip
for the Jedi side comes from when Yoda
raises Luke's x-wing out of the big of a
swamps an x-wing is a 10 metric tonne
spaceship and Yoda lifts it slowly
enough that we'll assume he's exerting
just a bit more force than the force of
gravity on Dagobah which according to
wikipedia is 1.1 3 times that of Earth
with this we can calculate Yoda's max
force force its forces Force is for
force if you will for team whiz we'll
look at when Percival graves
spoiler alert Grindelwald throws a Ford
Model T car at Tina figuring out when
Grindelwald z' hand waves are applying
force to the car is a bit hand wavy but
let's at least assume his magic is
responsible for the car's vertical
movement well has to meet this by
looking at how long it takes the car to
stop moving in the vertical direction
gravity pulls on the car as it moves up
eventually the car stops and starts
falling back down to earth knowing the
force of gravity and the time it takes
to stop moving up we can calculate the
initial velocity with the initial
velocity in hand we can calculate the
car's change in momentum and hence the
max force of his magic now that we know
the max force of each we can calculate
how long it would take them to yank over
a butterbeer from 50 meters there's a
catch though if they accelerate the beer
the entire way to their hand it'll be
going about
1,000 miles per hour by the time it hits
them so the first 25 meters they'll pull
it over
and the second 25 they'll push so it
stops right when it hits they're thirsty
mints
it'll take criminal Colin Farrel 32
milliseconds to pull the beer to him at
a safe speed while Yoda crafty little
guy takes just 28 milliseconds to do the
same Wizards lose day dude to a Jedi
have and point number 2 goes to the
force for a final challenge we're asking
what can output more power a lightsaber
or a magic wand now I don't want to get
too deep into semantics here because of
course a wand is useless without a
wizard while any old janitor can swing a
lightsaber but we'll treat the wizard
wand combo as a singular unit with the
wizard acting similar to the Kyber
crystal that powers the lightsaber hear
that Ron you're a human battery so for
the cleanest shot of a lightsabers raw
power we can use the scene where qui-gon
tries to mount the blast doors on the
space station Advanta Menace well assume
the doors are made of a known material
like steel and see how much energy and
time it takes for the saber to melt it
we could also ask them eight the length
and width of his lightsaber and use that
to help us estimate the thickness of the
blast doors making the case for magic
wands let's use the duel between
Dumbledore wielding the Elder Wand
and Voldemort in order of the Phoenix
early in the scene we see them both
shoot powerful blasts from their wands
meeting halfway between the two a bright
sphere appears where the magic energy
meets well assume this is a high
temperature plasma and that is in
thermodynamic equilibrium with the
surrounding environment first we can use
the RGB value of the sphere to roughly
estimate its temperature then if we
treat the sphere as a blackbody radiator
we can use this to fajn Boltzmann law to
estimate the energy it radiates to
clarify some terms real quick a
blackbody radiator is an object where
the spectrum or color only depends on
the temperature and the stefan-boltzmann
law lets you find out how much power is
being radiated from a blackbody if you
know its temperature science the
lightsaber takes tchau
number three with 64 megawatts of power
output to a paltry forty-three megawatts
for the Elder Wand so in a shocking
upset to Potterheads everywhere the
force wins the most challenges and is
crowned the most powerful now obviously
magic wins for sheer versatility no one
in star wars can conjure a magic stag or
turn the relative into a pig but maybe
that's cuz the Jedi train all the fun
out of you as a youngling oh well the
show is called power levels not
versatility levels and the force was
just too strong today
and if you disagree too bad the data
doesn't care about your feelings but we
care about you let us know you'd like to
see face off and you could see it right
here in the next episode of power levels
[Music]
you